I can't remember much before all this  started sometimes I feel like this has  been my whole life  ready  killing  my name is Alice and this is my story  the end my story  ten years ago in Raccoon City there was  an outbreak it spread across the world  within days  one way or another our world is coming  to an end the question is would we end  with it  umbrella developed an airborne antivirus  it would destroy the t-virus I have no  reason to believe a word you say true  but I can obviously want very much  revenge I have to get to the hive  we go together what I'm gonna do we're  gonna kill every last one of them  grab some gear  this is what I do  we play the long day you and I but now  it's over  [Music]  said all you got  we played